واحنا على ايش المشكله
نايمين
أنا اولادي اولادي اولاد بنتي كليتنا
طيب ممتاز ايش المشكله الان يعني انت بدك
بيت اه بدك خيمته بدي بيت نبرك يعني
طيب جربتي في في المخيم المجاور انه تسالي
ماذا قالوا لك
بخيمه يعني المشكله ان شاء الله انحلت
ونحن سته يعني خيمتين بدنا ان شاء الله
طيب انتو راح تسكنوا مؤقتا هون تبقوا هون
ولا راح تنتقلوا
قدرنا نطلع لبره
مفهوم مفهوم البيت انهدم ندم البيت كنا
شفت
مفهوم ان شاء الله ان شاء الله المشكله
تحل ان شاء الله ان شاء الله المشكله تحل
العيال المشاكل كثيره جدا طبعا وشكاوى
كثيره جدا بانه بطبيعه الحال الوضع لا
ابرر ولكن نعم
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله المشكله ستحلل ان شاء الله
المشكله ستحلل